people's getting soft man people
is getting soft dude they're not fully
baking people anymore
some people they seem like like i was
when i was born i was baked at probably
about 450 degrees
for nine months you know what i'm saying
that's how to
that that's how i rolled out a mama
but you got mfr's out here some soft
batch
cotton boys out here just
dude here's what happened so i went to
this town called bowling green
kentucky and it is the home of a
fruit of the loom drawers
so if you ever been wearing in fruit of
the looms baby you know if you ever got
your fruit all
loomed up then you know them them
[ __ ] came straight out of kentucky
that's basically kentucky that's holding
you nuts bruh
kentucky just holding your ivories bruh
gotcha
um you know they're just supporting your
low batch daddy but um
what i'm telling you is this so i went
there
to look at some different vehicles i've
been vehicle shopping
so i decided i'm gonna get me a hotel
stay over there for the for the evening
dude the guy behind i go knock on the
door of the hotel
and i understand it's core of at times
bro the disease is out
so first the guy comes to the window of
the hotel the door
glass door and looks at me like i'm
covered like
oh who's here is covet here like [ __ ]
i'm not covet
you know what i'm saying i'm regular
baby
so anyway the guy it was just so
ridiculous
like looking at me like he was going to
be able to judge if i had the disease
through the glass
so anyway he lets me inside and um
i was like say hey man do you guys have
a room here like yeah we got a room uh
let me go see if it's clean or not i was
like all right you know when he goes
upstairs
literally he's upstairs for probably
about 15 minutes obviously he should
have cleaned it earlier
that's in his job description
and he didn't and how do i know that
because i've been
a lazy [ __ ] like this dude
that's why
that's why i know because i've been that
dude
i've been the dude that shows up to work
and doesn't work
and i look i did i was really good at
that
so anyway man finally he comes down
and uh at this point i'm thinking i
might as well just i might just want to
drive back
um you know it's only like an hour and a
half to where i'm go
to back home to my place here so anyway
so
whatever he's looking on the computer
and stuff and
and at a certain point i'm kind of get
i'm getting antsy
you know it's been a while and it's
getting late i want to go get something
to eat and i know restaurants are kind
of closing a lot of things closing out
like eight o'clock
nine o'clock so i'm giving him a little
bit of pressure you know like um
you know can you uh can you run my card
or you know
is there anything i can do to help
saying stuff like that like a passive
aggressive
that's what they call it um
when you pretend like you are um a teddy
bear but you really a bad [ __ ] kinda
you know um
so anyway sorry finally he goes look i'm
sorry sir
okay but i just need you to relax a
little bit i used to be in a wheelchair
like what bro
you used to be in a wheelchair you used
to be
that's what we're doing now people are
just saying you know
look hey man look i
i used to weigh 11 pounds nine ounces
when i was born okay calm down
cut me some slack here
that guy said i used to be in a
wheelchair when [ __ ] you broke your leg
once
you know you did some [ __ ] dirty
karate somewhere bruh
i just don't know it just man
don't make me hit you with that rat
jitsu bruh
tighten this white dude up
sorry man i'm sorry getting out of line
but it just
man i don't know man that [ __ ] i like i
it just like hey hey buddy
look i had acne when i was 14. if you
could give me a little bit of room here
okay hey hey guys
you know i vomited uh in the middle of
the school play
when i was nine okay if you could just
step back and show some respect
it's just like what are we doing man
hey man i used to be in a wheelchair
well [ __ ] then get in a wheelchair now
if you in it
you know i'm sorry man but that [ __ ]
just got me heated up
like somebody just threw some damn warm
briquettes in my ass
bro you know that's where i'm at with
this [ __ ] just
hey hey man look you know i
i was a i was i used to be four years
old okay i was only three and a half
feet tall at one time
if you could give me a little bit of
room here
it's just like now we're like using
whatever our weakest moment was as our
front
and i don't mind us sharing our weakest
moment man i think there's a level of
connection there there's an opportunity
you know
you know it's like we're trading
vulnerability you know
you know uh we're trading um
baseball cards there you know i'll give
you
you know i feel uncomfortable outfielder
and you give me a um
look man sometimes i'm insecure
shortstop and
you know we we recognize each other from
those spaces
but i don't know if saying like look man
you know somebody burned my hair off
once
okay could you give me a little bit of
give me some give me a moment
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be
so far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been